I'm swimmable money from Microsoft
Research Redmond and I am going to show
you some interesting extension of the
flash fill technology in Excel 2013
flash will allows you to perform
so-called syntactic transformations on
strength and I'm going to show you how
we can extend this technology to also
perform semantic transformations on
strings so consider this table on the
right side where the user wants to map
the item name in the first column and
the selling date in the second column to
the selling price which you see in the
third column so the output column the
selling price is not a syntactic
transformations of the two input column
on the left in fact performing this
transformation requires making use of
some background knowledge which the user
has in the form of two user-defined
tables on the left side so in particular
what the user wants to do is to take a
join of the two tables on the left side
with the item ID column then index the
resultant table with item end date which
are the two input columns of the table
on the right then extract markup and
purchase price then perform some
synthetic transformations such as remove
the percentage sign from markup or
remove the dollar sign from the purchase
price and then connect them according to
this formula that you see at the top now
our interesting extension can perform
all of this with just the click of a
button so once you hit the apply button
then that will automatically figures out
which tables in the current worksheet
are is relevant how to join them what
columns to project on what syntactic
transformations to apply before indexing
what synthetic transformations to apply
after indexing and so on now the same
technology can also understand semantics
of different data items that you have in
your worksheet so consider the task of
formatting numbers to two decimal places
not your programming in C C++ C sharp
Java Python every language has its own
syntax for formatting numbers but the
teachers here is that again examples are
a universal wait
express intent and you do not need to
remember the various format identifier
so if you simply provide us a couple of
examples of what you want to do and hit
the apply button then that tool will
automate your intent the same technology
can also be used to manipulate let's say
dates and the flash will technology will
not be able to figure out that if six is
June and three is Marsh then eight ought
to be August and so on but since our new
version has an understanding of the
semantic data types it can help you
perform such semantic manipulations now
let me show you something little bit
different which is about manipulating
tables as a single entity as opposed to
simply manipulating strings and side
tables so in this scenario which is
taken from a health forum the user wants
to convert the table on the top left to
the table on the top right with the
intent being that since andrew has three
qualifications in the top-left table the
user wants three entries for Andrew in
the top right table similarly Ben has
two qualifications so the user wants two
entries for Ben furthermore the user
wants to color all qualifications one in
red all qualifications to in green and
so on and the real heartening thing
about this scenario is that this is
exactly how the end user describes it to
an expert on the help forum by means of
an example and the user is willing to
pay twenty dollars to anyone who gives
them a script to automate this task so
now let me show you how we can do this
for free using our system so in this see
why the user provides the coordinates of
the example input table then the
coordinates of the example output table
and the reason why the user once you
learn a script that can convert the
top-left table into the top right table
is because the user one should run this
script on presumably some large input
table like the one on the bottom left
and once the user hits okay then that
tool and supplying a script that can
convert the top-left table into the top
side table and then apply the descrip to
the bottom left able to generate the
desired bottom right table